can you uh can you take us through the
last possession and and also whether you
thought about yourself calling a timeout
or if you thought a timeout could have
helped uh no we talked about it uh
before hers both before both of his free
throws and
um me and
Coach kind of agree like we're going
we're going to take it kind of thinking
you're going to be down three knowing
he's a good shooter
and he missed the first one so I like
right yeah we're still going to going to
go expecting he was going to make the
second one and know you'd be down too
and kind of understand the situation and
then once he missed the second one Klay
got a great rebound but we had already
committed to going um and at that point
it's obviously chaos just trying to get
over half court see where the defense
was you know and once JK gave it to me
at that point like that's probably where
the timeout I either should have seen it
or coach or whoever just just to know
there's like eight people on one side of
court
and we had a screen they trapped and I
was trying to get the ball back to
Draymond to see what could happen so I
would say there probably should have
been a
timeout right when I got the ball and
turn and saw that the court wasn't
balanced right and we still have plenty
of time but you know the chaos of the
moment you're trying to make a play and
sometimes it works out sometimes it
doesn't